اذا نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا هذا الفيديو
وهو طبعا الفيديو المتداول في الصفحات
مقربه
للجيش السوداني نشرت هذا الفيديو فيديو
للسيطره على معسكر كرري التابع لقوات
الدعم السريع في ام درمان اذا الجيش
السوداني ينشر مقطعا
لقوته عبر صفحات
مقربه طبعا للجيش السوداني مقطع مصور
للقوات قوات الجيش السوداني داخل معسكر
كرري اكبر قاعده للدعم السريع في ام درمان
الجيش السوداني كان قد اعلن السيطره على
عدد من المراكز والمقرات التابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع في اكثر من ولايه
وهذا المعسكر معسكر كرري اذا
هو المعسكر اذا
المعسكر الذي تمت السيطره عليه في هذا
الفيديو من قبل الجيش السوداني نستمع ثم
نعود اكبر الله اكبر
استلامه
واذكر كرري السريع
عرباتهم ومدرعاتهم
مبروك
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات